with the guy who continues to be
at or near the top of the nfl news stack
tim tebow and the jaguars doing their
best to knock him down but oh he
continues to bubble up something that i
reported yesterday morning and credit to
trey wingo during the draft during that
not during the draft but the first day
of the draft when there was the
avalanche of aaron rodgers reporting
he had pointed out that rogers
believed that the packers at one point
in the offseason had told him miles that
they would trade aaron rodgers and then
they reversed course
i've continued to hear that
now the packers regard that as
unequivocally false and from the packers
perspective
their attitude is
we're not aware that's an issue and
you'd like to think that
if you got a guy
who believes he'd been told he was going
to be traded
and then the rug gets pulled out from
under him
when we don't trade him and we say we're
not going to trade him you think that at
some point someone would say to us but
you said
you were going to trade him
but even with that
the sense the story the notion the room
or whatever label you want to apply it
continues to ricochet around the nfl so
there's something there that hasn't been
fully knocked down that rogers believes
something was said
to make him think they were going to
trade him which made him even more upset
when they didn't especially when there
was an offer on the table from the 49ers
that the packers rejected a night before
the draft and pay no attention that man
behind the curtain there was a real
offer made this wasn't a hey you don't
want to trade aaron rodgers do you know
what the hell are you talking about okay
bye have a good draft it was much more
than that rogers wanted to go to san
francisco
and the packers shut it down miles
well so here's the thing right like it
it seems like there is a there there
between aaron rodgers and the packers
and whatever it is that made him so mad
that caused this schism you know this
fissure to be in the relationship and
whether that started with jordan love
getting drafted or it started in the
soft season where you know after aaron
rodgers plays really well he performs
like an mvp and they know that they
still have a guy in jordan love that is
eventually going to be the starting
quarterback of the green bay packers
then they have to say all right well we
are going to do something
uh to remedy this situation to make it
better and i guess that's the impression
that aaron rodgers got was that i'm
going to be traded and that's going to
be the remedy to the situation but like
how would that make any sense
why would green bay decide oh yeah we're
actually going to trade you reigning mvp
that's something that makes a lot of
sense from our standpoint when we've got
you under contractual control for the
next couple years i like
logically i can say like okay aaron
rodgers might have believed that he
would be traded but why would he think
that that would actually be something
that would happen
and you just wonder whether or not at
the core of this there's some sort of
screwy madcap sitcom premise
where
a big crazy misunderstanding happens and
you spend the rest of the 22 minutes
trying to resolve it only to have some
lightning bolt instant that wraps it all
up so they can end the show and move on
to the next one that begins at 8 30 pm
eastern time on tuesday night that's
what it feels like to me that somebody
said something that caused someone to
think something that just kind of
festered because the communication and
the entire relationship has been so
dysfunctional it wouldn't surprise me at
all if rogers genuinely believed or
heard what he wanted to hear and
processed it the way he wanted to
process it because of his perspective
and from the packers perspective like
what the hell are you talking about of
course we were never going to trade you
why did you think that we were ever
going to entertain that possibility
so
look it's just another piece of a puzzle
that creates a picture
that we don't know what the hell it is
the pieces are coming together and we
don't know what the hell it is and to
add to our collection of pieces that we
don't know what the hell they are aaron
jones packers running back appeared with
rich eisen yesterday on
the topic of ultimately and inevitably
the status of quarterback aaron rodgers
here's aaron jones talking about his
quarterback
back i mean i see what everybody else
sees i mean i haven't heard from
aaron or anybody so i'm just i'm gonna
wait till
i get up to green bay and see for myself
or hear hear it from him myself you know
it's just i don't get caught up in the
reading articles and things like that
i'll just wait until it plays out and
control what i can control what's your
sense do you think week one when you're
in new orleans you're gonna be grabbing
a ball from 12 i mean that's my
quarterback that's our quarterback uh
so i would hope so like i said i hope
he's our quarterback hope he's there
week one
handing it off
and it all works out
you know aaron jones deliberately
choosing not to find anything out not to
determine
where this is all going not speaking to
rogers not seeking out information just
kind of going with the flow look he got
his contract
and he's getting a decent amount of
money he probably got more from the
packers than he would have gotten on the
open market one of the reasons why he
did that deal before he went to the open
market he had exhausted i believe
given the way these things are done
exhausted all opportunities elsewhere
before deciding to stay with the green
bay packers and take their eight figure
per year offer so you know he's in the
the honeymoon phase
of renewing his vows with the green bay
packers
and and you know this is my broader
concern miles if you're aaron jones
if you're devante adams if you're any
other player on that team there will be
a point
where
being asked these questions over and
over again
will
become tiresome
and it just underscores the fact
that at some point aaron rodgers does
need to say something my new friend john
kuhn apparently yesterday making the
argument that aaron rodgers owes us
nothing by way of an explanation well
you know what if all of his current
former teammates are going to have to do
the talking on his behalf at some point
he owes it to them
to eliminate
this mess that they have to deal with
because aaron refuses to talk and
they're all out there talking and
they're the ones that have to deal with
all the questions
yeah exactly look
that's so funny
i'm one week closer to having john
kuhn's trunk searched
yeah no doubt see
i will find you
um that's really interesting john kuntz
let me say something miles let me say
something somebody responded to that by
saying gee what is this who's this guy
think he is somebody's actually looking
for him hit says i will find you with an
exclamation point how else am i supposed
to interpret that
i don't know i have no idea how you
should interpret that other than like by
interpreting what it says john [ __ ]
thinks that the same thing about you
that aaron rodgers does apparently man
but he's gone a step further because
all aaron rodgers says is don't read
that crap from mike florio john [ __ ]
wants to find you his first mistake
that's interesting yeah i guess so look
i think that you're right that there's
definitely going to be a point where
it's just not fair for guys like aaron
jones and devante adams to have to go on
the radio in their media appearances and
just have to answer questions about
aaron rodgers because that's the only
topic that matters about the packers
right now it does not matter that you
know it's very nice that erin jones has
13 million guaranteed reasons to be okay
with what's going on there right now
because he just got his but if you're
somebody like devante adams you'd
probably rather be thinking about hey
man how are we going to not just get
back to the nfc championship game but
actually reach the super bowl this year
and if you all you have to do is just
answer questions about your quarterback
who is still the reigning mvp
that's gonna wear on you at a certain
point i don't know if that's now because
these guys aren't still aren't doing
regular media you know i mean otas are
going to start soon and then there's
probably still going to be some sort of
zoom press conferences and that means
that guys can get shielded in some
certain ways but look
until aaron rodgers starts speaking for
himself
it's really kind of not fair to those
guys who have to speak for him who are
not the i'm retired and i'm a surrogate
and i will find you mike florio types of
people who are you know making their
money basically off of the media now
i saw a clip from whatever show it is
that john [ __ ] does yesterday and he
just doesn't
seem to understand the very basic chain
of logic that is running through this he
speaks to aaron rodgers and then he
speaks publicly about his beliefs
regarding the things that aaron rodgers
wants or will do or that this is fixable
and if aaron rodgers continues to speak
to him
after he does those things
he's clearly being used by rogers to get
the word out because if rogers wasn't
happy with the things he was saying he
would no longer talk to him he would no
longer tell him things he would text him
or call him and say john listen these
things you and i are talking about
they're meant for private consumption
one of kun's arguments is i'm not out
there
seeking to be on these shows well so
what so what you're still agreeing to do
it and you're still agreeing to talk
about it i speak to aaron rodgers
and this is what i think he wants and
again there's a chance that that kuhn is
one of various pawns on the chessboard
that aaron rodgers is manipulating and
[ __ ] is slowly in the process of coming
to the realization that that's the case
so uh regardless john hey and john
anytime you want to talk about it i'm
easy to find i'm i'm very easy to find
and i'll be even easier to find if i'm
dead in the trunk of your car okay uh
let's move on on that happy note um
one week quarterbacks
one week closer to death baby and one
way closer to getting resolution more
importantly the aaron rodgers situation
because look miles otas
he's either going to be there or he's
not mandatory mini camp he's either
going to be there or he's not training
camp he's going to be there or he's not
in between that annual shareholder
meeting which could be very interesting
if aaron rodgers is poised to hold out i
still think he's going to show up i
think comments by guys like [ __ ] and
james jones are intended to lay the
foundation so aaron can show up and say
what's a big deal what's a big deal and
maybe one last ditch effort to get him
the contract that he's looking for that
would tie the packers to him for
multiple years making the jordan love
presence moot and irrelevant and
potentially put him on the trade block
well mike mike when is your drop dead
time of when there's either going to be
some sort of resolution to this whether
it's aaron rodgers new contract aaron
rodgers gets traded or maybe jordan love
gets traded
i well
i i think that the start of training
camp because i think that's when the
packers fans go to defcon one if he's
not there for mandatory minicamp they
probably get to defcon too
but but if he is not there
at the beginning of official training
camp with the bicycles
and the cheese heads and just you know
it's it's it's love and family and
football all together and and i'm not
saying that sarcastically it's a special
time
if he gives a middle finger to the
organization and indirectly to the fans
and doesn't show up for that that's when
i think
it's it's go time and uh i think that if
they're going to get anything fixed they
need to do it by the start of training
camp and we'll see and look the packers
may continue to say we're not doing a
damn thing you're not getting a new
contract you're not getting it you've
already gotten a lot of money from us
under this contract you're a big boy
you're smart you want the cal you know
what this contract meant when you signed
it and you knew that when we got to the
out years we're the ones who hold the
cards not you so if you don't want to
play don't play we'll take our 30
million back that you owe us and uh
we'll move forward we'll spend that
money on other players so i think by the
start of training camp we'll get a final
resolution and i think he'll be there
and he'll
he'll remind people not to read the crap
that i right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports